- [Mark] All right, Darryl,
where did you grow up?
Where are you from, originally?
- New Orleans, Louisiana.
- And tell me about your family,
you had both with your parents growing up?
- Both of my parents... nine kids.
- Nine kids, how was your childhood?
- A child who is very, very rough
and, as I could go back as...
Remembering a lot of things
when I was five years old.
I remember the abusive,
physical things that my dad done to me,
through his alcoholism.
And, I have a twin sister,
and because I'm the youngest about,
I'm the youngest boy,
out of the four and the five girls, but,
I grew up real hard,
I don't know what it was,
but, my dad really chastised me
through a lot of things that,
he hindered, one of my biggest dreams,
and one of my biggest dreams,
wanted to be an NFL football player,
but through the beatings,
I have a stab wound, my
father actually cut me
he stabbed me, I almost lost my life,
and I was six years old at that time, but,
through that childhood,
and like I said, coming up
I was abused constantly.
I can come home from school
and my dad would find some
crazy reason to just beat on me,
and my mom would do
everything in her power
to stop him,
and I was the only child,
out of the nine kids,
that my father abused.
Today, when I looked back at it,
my father saw some things in me
that he wanted to do.
I just, I'm gonna keep it at the point,
where he just abused me, you know?
Deprived me of anything
that I wanted to do,
and, I just tried
everything I could to excel,
but I left home at age of 15.
I was playing music and
I started traveling,
I got tired of (indistinct)
different nationalities.
And drugs became a part of my life,
I started using drugs at age 15.
I'd been in penitentiary five times,
assaults, token guns,
using drugs, prostitution.
I was actually shutting myself, you know,
in New Jersey, in New York,
I've been, damn near
to the brink of death,
people have beaten.
My life was just harsh.
And my father, my mom,
for my mom and pappy lived,
they stayed married 62 years, but,
I was in prison when my father died,
he's been gone six years now, and...
He never really...
He never actually told
me that he loved me.
I was the son of my father
didn't do anything for,
And, I finished high school barely.
But I've excelled,
in my life, a lot more
than my other brothers,
but I was never given compassionate,
I was never awarded with
any type of affection,
any of those things.
At the age of 19, I can
go back and remember,
when I did my first, gospel
album, as a professional drummer
I recall my dad,
punching me in my face.
He didn't want me to do these things,
and he told me I was not permitted
to even come around the house
because I was a child that,
did what I wanted to do, and
not what he wanted me to do.
And it confused me,
It really confused me to the point where,
I thought about suicide,
I actually thought
about killing my father,
I really did, you know,
I wanted to blew this
man's brains out, man.
And we could never hold a conversation,
and I would always try to...
I wanted to, reach out to
my dad, and talk him cause,
I had friends that grew
up with their fathers,
and their fathers did things for them.
Back when I played baseball,
my father wouldn't come to my games.
And when I did come from the games,
I would even get cussed
out, punched in the mouth,
caught all kinds of bitches and whores,
that, "You'll never be any fucking thing."
You know?
And man, this really, redirected my path.
And I strayed away from my home,
and I abandoned my family,
I wanted to love my mama and she loved me.
But I just straight away
from home and, took a path,
and like, man, that,
just totally fuck me up.
And I'll never forget my
first time going penitentiary,
for armed robbery.
I did seven years.
Come home, stayed home, six months.
Went back to the penitentiary,
distribution of drugs, in five years.
Dating back out, did
another spend, three years,
I shot a man.
And just this last time,
I've been on five years now,
this last time,
they got me for fraud, writing bad checks.
And, when I looked back over
everything that happened to me,
it still hurts me.
As I talk to you right now,
I have pain in my heart
cause my father has (mumbles)
I still never heard the words
to say that you loved me,
and I want so bad right now,
to tell my father that I love him,
through all,
the neglect
that he threw upon me,
and the weight at my foot, man.
The weight that my father put on me,
it still, bothers me because,
I still don't have an answer, to why?
Here I am now, from new Orleans
and traveling to California,
not knowing why?
I'm, I still have a Gypsy
spirit, to move around,
and to try to find out,
what it is? What is it?
What's my achievement in his life?
And every time I try to figure
this thing out, I process it.
The hard thing of what
my father done to me,
and to hear those words that,
"You'll never be anything,
You a, bitch.
You're no good, child."
And I think about the beatings,
stitching cards, belts, chains, boards.
You name it.
I'm still confused,
and I'm 54 years old now,
and I still haven't
figured out, my directive.
And as I said, I came here to California,
(mumbles)
I was on Skid Row,
for some kind of reason, I should...
I don't even know that answer.
I figured out a way to
come out of this shit.
But as I say, the haunting of
my father's, torture to me,
and his words, they
still echo in my brain.
And I'm still under a lot of hindrance,
I'm still a user today.
I drank excessively.
I have a job.
But my days, are my nights,
are not completed,
without the use of me, using drugs.
And I do this here to
state, my father's voice.
He haunted me day and night.
I still feel the pain,
I still feel that the whipping,
the lashings that he placed upon me.
And sometime me and my twin sister,
which, we talked every day,
I called my mom every day.
And my mom got me all the time, she said,
"Darryl, I still can
hear it in your voice,
the pain that you're going through, son."
She said, "Your father was a
confused man, an educated man,
that didn't have a clue to what,
he was supposed to do,
but he tortured me."
And I don't know if you
knew anything about torture.
I can go back, as far
as I remember, my dad,
actually put me in the basement,
for a weekend and left me there.
No food, no water.
And work it out with my mom
to even bring anything to me,
or even my siblings.
And (indistinct) used to cry out to daddy,
"Why, daddy?
Why, Darryl?"
What he did?
And he would, push them away, smack them
through his alcoholism.
He killed me,
he killed himself.
And I still feel this pain every day.
And I see me,
on my father, I see my father, in me now.
I'm not as deep as he was in alcoholism
but I see the things that he did to me.
I inject this on,
anybody that comes in my presence.
I don't have...
I can't have healthy
relationships or anything,
because I'm abusive like
my father was, to me.
It's scary,
and I really wish I can
just find the answers, man,
to come out.
I'm holding back the tears right now
because I'm really hurting
from this shit, man.
Knowing that I was on the streets,
getting with women and homosexuals.
Fuck!
Just this morning before I went to work,
a homosexual ruled at me.
(murmurs) asking me to describe my penis.
And I got in the car with him.
And in my ignorance
of not knowing what the hell
is going on with myself.
I indulge with this man.
I want this shit to stop,
and I need answers.
And I just pray to my
higher power all the time,
"Please help me."
And I believe, he tries to talk to me,
but my spirit is so dull
from five years old, up to 54 now.
I just can't understand it,
and I need help bad,
real bad.
I can't even, I don't even know
how to talk to my own kids.
I don't...
My son was born,
I was in penitentiary.
I never knew my son, up
until five years ago,
when both of us walked the same hallways,
in the penitentiary.
That was my one of my nightmares,
losing my mom and dad
while I was locked up
or even meeting my child.
And it was all right that this guy,
seen me one day, and he said,
"Man, you look just like Kiarra."
I knew that name, but I knew
who he was talking about.
And I asked this guy where he was from,
and he told me, "I checked
with my son for him."
He said, "Man, your son
is in the cell block."
I managed to get a letter to him,
and asked him to meet me in the chapel.
And that's where I met my child at.
My child,
was 21 years old,
a grown man.
I never got to hold him,
never heard him say his
first words, anything.
And just said that, say,
discard from what my father did to me,
my son could even call me, dad,
And I wanted his respect, as his father
or I couldn't command that
because, I wasn't a father.
I just wanted to reach out,
and beat him like my father did me.
Cause I'd met you in prison,
and I felt like my dad felt about me,
"Son you ain't gone be shit, shit!
You'll never achieve anything in life."
I talked to him the
same way my father did,
and that wasn't healthy.
I believe that them scars
are still with my son
because my son is back
in penitentiary, again.
I just gotta try to figure out a way
to get my spiritual, my spirit right.
And hopefully I can do
it before I pass away,
and give my son a different direct,
than what I had as a child.
(indistinct) a bitch until you die.
When I'm hoping, someday,
that I can figure it out.
Being in California,
and living in a heart that
I've lived in Skid Row.
Man...
it is so confusing,
it is so hurting
when I walked the streets,
and see where the fuck
my life has brought me
from my child abuse.
And I bring everything that
is happening to me today,
I still blame it from what my father did,
because he never educated me.
All you ever deal with (indistinct)
and said that I would be
overriding son of a bitch,
and that's where my life is today.
That's where my life be is,
It hurts, bro.
It hurts. It is, you know,
I know you...
You're a busy man, I appreciate,
you just hear my story.
Just a little bit that I've
shared with you right now,
it makes me feel a little
bit better because,
I'm having an opportunity to release
because here in Skid Row,
I have no other...
He's bottled up in there.
I'm an angry man,
I'm a violent man
On my job,
I'm known for a good employee.
And at the same time, I'm known for,
anything that grips, gets out of order
with a customer,
I'm the one called upon, because of my...
they don't know about it,
but because of that anger
that I distribute.
I'm called upon, to fuck shit up.
I've been asked, I've been asked today
When I go back to work,
and get off at six o'clock.
I've been asked
to literally, break a guy's bones
for what he done.
And I've already volunteered
to do these things,
cause I don't give a fuck.
As I said,
I was told, I wouldn't be shit.
So, I don't give a shit,
I don't give a shit,
Whether I died by the
gun, the knife, whatever.
And this is why I'm a loner,
I keep people distant from me.
I'm a widow, I had a wife.
And my dad abused my wife, my mom.
And my third year of marriage,
I literally beat, my wife so bad,
on the streets,
I didn't even know, undercover
police were right there.
And one of them touched me, I stopped him.
I placed so much fear in my wife.
God bless her, she's
deceased now, from lupus.
This lady, we used to be scared
to even say good morning to me.
Because I treated her,
like my dad treated my mom.
I would tell her,
"Bitch, get out my face."
When we breakfast,
I would eat the food, and
literally throw the plate at her.
I had and still have,
a destructive,
mindset and spirit.
Once I walk out the door,
and I set the pattern of my destination,
it's not healthy for anybody
to even anything to me.
Cause I don't give a fuck about myself,
and I don't give a fuck
about the next person.
And that's a destructive lifestyle.
Maybe I'll dive over.
Maybe I'll get (mumbles) opportunity
and find out something,
that can derail me
from this destructive
path, that I'm walking on.
Well, then my closing.
I want some help
because I'm tired of abusing me,
and the people that come into my life,
and that's why
I don't have anymore, I don't.
Just as soon as I meet you, trust me,
you'll be glad to get out of my presence
because I don't give a fuck.
Peace.
- Right there, thank you very much.
- Thank you, man.
- Good to talk about.
- Right. You helped me today, you did.
You helped me today, about that.
- Therapy is a great thing.
- Man, just, man.
- Do this regularly,
imagine if you did this
like three times a week.
- That would be different.
- You would be a different man.
- (murmurs) I'm so tired man, hey...